[Música]
amigos arizona es un estado famoso por
el gran cañón del colorado sus minas de
cobre y sus cactus porque si algo
escasea en este estado es precisamente
la lluvia
ahora bien tener un clima semidesértico
no ha impedido que arizona sea el estado
en el que más rápido está creciendo la
población de todos los estados unidos-
para que os hagáis una idea actualmente
en arizona viven el doble de personas
que hace apenas 30 años acaban de
superar los 7 millones de habitantes de
hecho es muy llamativo ver como estados
vecinos bastante similares como por
ejemplo nevada nuevo méxico o incluso
yuta tienen prácticamente la mitad de
población que arizona y os estaréis
preguntando y esto por qué demonios pasa
pues parece que la respuesta es evidente
por la inmigración
[Música]
los datos demográficos ofrecen pocas
dudas un 30 por ciento de la población
de arizona es de origen hispano cuando
hace 30 años éstos apenas representaban
el 19 por ciento y ojo porque el peso de
la población hispana no va a dejar de
crecer desde el año 2017 los nacimientos
de madre latina son superiores a los de
cualquier otro colectivo y claro con los
años todo esto tendrá un efecto sobre el
electorado arizona porque los menores de
18 años no pueden votar ahora pero que
puedan votar es sólo una cuestión de
tiempo por eso un informe de la
universidad estatal de arizona estima
que la proporción hispana del electorado
crecerá del 15% en 2010 al 25% en 2030
así que queridos amigos de visual
política la conclusión es sencilla
arizona a un estado que en 2016 dio su
apoyo a donald trump para llegar a la
casa blanca es cada vez más hispano en
este vídeo vamos a ver cómo puede
influir todo esto de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales del 3 de
noviembre y de cara a futuros comicios
electorales atentos que comenzamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vamos a ver para entender bien las
elecciones de eeuu no podemos verlas
como las de un país cohesionado sino que
hay que ver las estado por estado y
arizona ha sido históricamente un feudo
republicano desde el final de la segunda
guerra mundial y la victoria del
demócrata harry truman en 1948 arizona
apoyó siempre al candidato presidencial
del partido republicano salvo en 1996 y
en aquella ocasión
bill clinton se impuso por la mínima sin
embargo ahora parece que todo esto
podría estar a punto de cambiar by the
lidera por ocho puntos en arizona sobre
trump según muestra una nueva encuesta
la importancia de arizona es
considerable especialmente para el
presidente trump porque pues básicamente
porque está bastante claro que las
posibilidades de trump de seguir la casa
blanca pasan por mantener los apoyos
obtenidos en 2016 ojo también para los
demócratas es más importante para bailén
ganar ahora en arizona que supone 11
votos en el colegio electoral que para
clinton cuando lo logró en 1996 pues
entonces sólo eran 8 votos o en tiempos
de harry truman cuando apenas eran 4
[Música]
arizona deje de ser un feudo republicano
puede convertirse en un gran quebradero
de cabeza para los republicanos porque
su importancia en el colegio electoral
está creciendo recordad que las
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu son
unas elecciones indirectas en realidad
los votantes eligen a 538 miembros del
colegio electoral cuya única función es
elegir al presidente y el vicepresidente
y en el que la distribución de sus
miembros van más o menos en función de
la población de cada estado recordad
también que otra particularidad de las
elecciones estadounidenses es que con la
excepción de nebraska y maine los
delegados no se reparten proporcional
sino que el candidato que gana se hace
con todos en arizona no importa que un
candidato gane las elecciones por un
voto por un millón lo importante es
ganar el candidato más votado se hará
con sus 11 votos en el colegio electoral
exactamente por eso arizona es tan
importante hablamos de 11 electores que
gana un candidato y los 11 electores que
deja de ganar el otro candidato hace 4
años 77 votos del colegio electoral se
pararon a trump y hillary clinton y con
estos cálculos arizona representaría por
sí solas 22 votos seguro seguro que ya
nos parece tan poca cosa así que la
pregunta es puede arizona dejar de ser
un feudo republicano y convertirse en un
swing states que nos hace pensar que las
gentes de ese estado van a votar por
bailén o que podrían quedarse contra
decidir adicional noviembre quiero
ocupar a la casa blanca durante los
próximos cuatro años hoy en visual
político vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
el viejo sheriff de maricopa el condado
de maricopa es uno de los 15 condados de
arizona allí se encuentra phoenix la
capital y la ciudad más poblada del
estado y os aseguro que no exageramos un
pelo si decimos que durante muchos años
las únicas noticias que nos llegaron
desde aquí eran las que protagonizaban
joe arpaio el viejo sheriff de maricopa
joe arpaio fue elegido en 1993 cuando
tenía 60 años sheriff del condado de
maricopa permaneció en el cargo durante
24 años hasta 2017 al ser reelegido
hasta en cinco ocasiones como ser y fue
siempre el candidato respaldado por el
partido republicano y él mismo se
autoproclamaba como el sheriff más duro
de toda norteamérica su fama alcanzó
incluso un nivel internacional por su
trato severo a los prisioneros y su
persecución a los inmigrantes ilegales
su mayor polémica fue la cárcel de texas
city y es que veréis antes de carballo
se convirtiera en sheriff el número de
reclusos de arizona extendía con creces
el máximo permitido así que a muchos se
les ponía libertad antes de cumplir su
condena para así poder cumplir con las
normas y evitar relacionamiento pero
amigos arpaio se inventó una solución en
cities
y
[Música]
una cárcel formada por tiendas de
campaña y vigilada por varitas de las
que colgaba un mensaje que ponía a
habitaciones libres de esta forma la
política carcelaria de arizona cambió de
repente todos los presos pasaron a
cumplir la condena íntegra porque al fin
y al cabo pues se necesitaba más sitio
ahí estaba de sheriff arpaio que te
montaba rápidamente otra tienda de
campaña claro que las condiciones no
eran precisamente las mejores montar una
campana en plena arizona no parece la
mejor idea del mundo fijaos por ejemplo
en esta noticia de hace tres años
arizona está alojando a presos en
tiendas de campaña y hace 47 grados
centígrados si arpaio quería que su
cárcel para decir al infierno está claro
que por calor no era luego están otros
detalles que tanto llamando la atención
de los medios de todo el mundo los
presos condenados generalmente por
delitos menores estaban obligados a
llevar ropa interior de color rosa y
trajes a rayas blancas y negras vamos
los clásicos de los presos sólo les
faltaban los grilletes y la cadena con
la bola arrastrada por el pie para
llevar el kit completo por supuesto como
os podéis imaginar las organizaciones
pro derechos humanos denunciaban que se
daba a los presos un trato de migrante
pero la cuestión es que en el fondo arpa
y estaba encantado de recibir tanta
atención claro que a la larga
tanto atención genera problemas y vaya
si arpaio los atn y los de las redadas
realizadas por el sheriff para buscar
inmigrantes ilegales provocaron durante
años acusaciones de discriminación
racial a esa conclusión llegó en 2011 un
juez federal ordenó arpaio poner fin a
sus controles de inmigración ya que
detenían a personas sin evidencia de
haber cometido ningún delito el veterano
sheriff no hizo ni caso y en 2017 fue
condenado por desacato criminal parpalló
se enfrentaba a una posible condena de
hasta seis meses de cárcel pero tiene
amigos muy poderosos en las elecciones
de 2016 mostró apoyo total a la
candidatura presidencial de donald trump
así que cuando fue condenado el
presidente acudió en su auxilio el
indulto
sí sí
[Música]
bye
fue el primer indulto de trump y no
contó con la aprobación de muchos
republicanos ni siquiera con la
aprobación del que fue durante tres
décadas senador por arizona john mccain
el señor arpaio fue declarado culpable
de desacato criminal por seguir
persiguiendo ilegalmente a los latinos
que viven en arizona por presuponer su
estatus migratorio violando así las
órdenes de un juez
el presidente tiene la autoridad para
otorgar este indulto pero hacerlo en
este momento socava su reclamo por el
respeto al estado de derecho ya que el
señor arpaio no ha mostrado
remordimiento por sus acciones john
mccain pues bien esta era la arizona que
en 2016 apoyó tras llegar a la
presidencia el condado de maricopa cuyos
votantes eligieron múltiples veces
arpaio
conocieron en imagínate el mismo
discurso contra la inmigración y las
mismas propuestas que ya habían
escuchado antes de su viejo ser y pero
dicho esto veamos cómo ha sido la
arizona de la edad trampa
[Música]
todos los muros del presidente
amigos en 2015 el 45º presidente de los
eeuu lanzó su carrera hacia la casa
blanca pronto dejó clara la opinión que
tiene sobre la migración mexicana
descendente por tener los problemas de
bring de los problemas gordos de
bringing drugs the brain in green the
lives and sam hay ese hombre del equipo
el primer mandato de donald trump como
presidente de los eeuu ha reformado
drásticamente el sistema migratorio de
este país desde que asumió el cargo su
administración emprendió atentos más de
400 acciones ejecutivas sobre
inmigración ahora bien la pregunta es
cumplió tras las promesas utilizadas
hace cuatro años para ganar votantes ha
cumplido acaso con un discurso que
muchos podrían tachar de populista pues
amigos parece que no o al menos no del
todo la promesa de construir un muro a
lo largo de la frontera entre eeuu y
méxico una de las promesas de campaña
más controvertidas de donald trump
el magnate hablaba de un muro de
hormigón de 1600 kilómetros con el resto
de la frontera asegurada por barreras
naturales
además trump también insistió en que
méxico lo pagaría y cifró su coste en
unos 8 mil millones de dólares sin
embargo cuatro años después la realidad
es que ni méxico ha puesto un peso ni
trampa ha construido el muro su muro
[Música]
y eso por no decirte un informe interno
del departamento de seguridad nacional
estimó que el dichoso muro propuesto por
el presidente costaría 21 mil 600
millones de dólares más del doble de lo
estimado por el magín ante este asunto
ha sido utilizado constantemente en las
peleas entre republicanos y demócratas y
como los demócratas han controlado la
cámara de representantes durante los
últimos años pues le han bloqueado la
asignación de fondos para el muro pero
tram declaró febrero del 2019 el estado
de emergencia nacional en la frontera y
así se pudo hacer con 15 mil millones de
dólares al desviar fondos de la lucha
contra el tráfico de drogas y del propio
ejército desde entonces el presidente
dice que ya se han construido ojo 480
kilómetros de muro pero lo que no cuenta
es que 420 kilómetros de estos 480 han
venido a sustituir o reparar estructuras
fronterizas ya existentes o que estaban
deterioradas eso sí espera un momento
porque el muro no es la única promesa en
materia de inmigración que el candidato
trap hizo en 2016
[Música]
también se comprometió a deportar a
todos los inmigrantes indocumentados
esta medida hubiera supuesto la
expulsión de eeuu de aproximadamente 11
3 millones de personas aunque eso sí el
candidato republicano fue suavizando su
postura a medida que avanzaba la campaña
electoral de 2016 tran redujo las
deportaciones prometidas a unos dos o
tres millones de personas prometiendo
concentrar sus esfuerzos en expulsar a
criminales pandilleros y
narcotraficantes
al final la realidad es que la cantidad
de personas deportadas por tramo en su
primer mandato ronda el millón de
personas aunque es verdad que ha
intentado expulsar a más pero se ha
encontrado una oposición enorme de hecho
una de las medidas más polémicas fue su
intento de acabar con el programa de
protección de menores inmigrantes de
obama tuvo que ser el tribunal supremo
de los estados unidos.el que le parara
los pies al fallar en contra de su
propuesta de rescindir la llamada daca
que protege a unos 650 mil jóvenes que
entraron en estados unidos sin papeles
cuando eran niños y por supuesto amigos
si algo ha cambiado contra ese ha sido
precisamente el discurso que se ha
vuelto muchísimo más hostil y no
olvidéis el peso que los hispanos tienen
ya en arizona pero sigamos si hablamos
de trump y del año 2020 es imposible no
hablar del dichoso coronavirus y aquí
está claro que el presidente no ha
encontrado el muro capaz de frenar la
pandemia vamos que se equivocó de muro
las cifras en estados unidos hablan por
si solas a estas alturas más de 8
millones de contagios y más de 220.000
fallecidos pues bien el mayor problema
para mi zona es que el 95 por ciento de
su población vive en núcleos urbanos
[Música]
arizona es el decimocuarto estado más
poblado de los eeuu sin embargo el hecho
de que la población esté más concentrada
en las ciudades ha incrementado la
incidencia del virus hablamos del octavo
estado con más casos más de 230.000
contagios y casi 6000 fallecidos en el
momento de preparar este vídeo de hecho
el gobernador de arizona el republicano
data si se vio obligado a decretar el
confinamiento de la población desde el
día 1 de abril durante mes y medio
el coronavirus ha hecho pedazos los
términos en los que pensábamos que podía
moverse y esta elección trajo
presumiendo de crecimiento económico
frente a los demócratas reivindicando
temas más sociales como las cuestiones
migratorias pero 2020 nos ha cambiado la
vida a todos también a los
estadounidenses ahora bien si levantamos
la vista dejamos un vistazo más allá
veremos que si algo ha cambiado
realmente durante estos últimos cuatro
años eso ha sido precisamente arizona
atentos
[Música]
la nueva zona
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ya nos lo hemos dicho antes arizona es
un feudo históricamente republicano y si
hace cuatro años dieron sus 11 electores
a donald trump confiaron en el magnate
pero desde entonces hemos visto en
arizona numerosos signos de divorcio
entre el presidente y el electorado
republicano o un factor seguramente
clave ha sido el desprecio con el que
trató en varias ocasiones al senador
john mccain
el que fuera candidato presidencial
contra obama nunca dudó en hacer pública
sus discrepancias con el magnate
álex plane
pero lo cierto es que las cosas van más
allá de cualquier pequeña polémica para
que os hagáis una idea además de los
terribles desprecios ataques que traen
dirigido hacia mccain en arizona se
sienten en realidad los guardianes del
alma conservadora del partido
republicano los herederos del senador
barry goldwater
[Música]
barry goldwater fue senador por arizona
durante 30 años y candidato presidencial
del partido republicano en las
elecciones de 1964 perdió ante lyndon
johnson pero su legado está considerado
como clave en el renacimiento del
movimiento conservador when water se
apoyó en una ideología liberal
concentrada en tres objetivos reducir el
poder del gobierno federal favorecer las
libertades económicas y políticas y
combatir el comunismo en el exterior el
resultado tuvo nombre y apellidos ronald
reagan
y el gas
the dark knight y despóticos
el distinto john mccain fue una voz
crítica contra el presidente trans pero
desgraciadamente a los seis meses de que
el magnate jugase su cargo le fue
diagnosticado el cáncer mortal así que
la voz del conservadurismo republicano
fue reivindicada entonces por el otro
senador de arizona
jeff flake condenó en un libro la
influencia de trump en el movimiento
conservador denunciaba a que el partido
republicano había renunciado a todas sus
creencias ideología a cambio del poder
ofrecido por alguien tan autoritario
populista como donald trump así lo
explica el propio senador cuando
anunciaba que no se presentaría a la
reelección
el senador republicano que por cierto
hoy apoya hay un baile
el mandato de jeff flake como senador
concluyó en 2018 que las elecciones al
senado para ocupar su vacante la
candidata del trump ismo marta max ali
fue derrotada hacía 30 años que el
partido demócrata no conseguía hacerse
con uno de los los puestos del senado
para arizona pues bien en las elecciones
de este 3 de noviembre se elegirá
también quien recoge la vacante tras la
muerte de john mccain max ali es de
nuevo la candidata republicana de perder
sería la primera vez desde 1952 que los
dos senadores por arizona pertenecen al
partido demócrata en este aspecto las
encuestas ofrecen pocas dudas eso es
exactamente lo que va a suceder
amigos la sensación que existe es que el
campismo se está desmoronando en arizona
de hecho los demócratas también ganaron
en la última elección para la cámara de
representantes e incluso el propio joe
arpaio el fiel seguidor de trump ha
sufrido tres reveses electorales perdido
el cargo de sheriff del condado de
maricopa antes de su oponente demócrata
luego hoy ha insultado compitió sin
éxito contra marta max ali para
presentarse al cargo de senador y ya
pues todos los republicanos le han dado
ni siquiera la oportunidad de que pueda
volver a ser elegido sería la estrella
de arpaio se apagó y veremos qué pasa
con tram porque lo cierto es que en
arizona no se vemos signos de que tras
mismo está en clara descomposición el ex
senador jeff flake y el ex representante
jim colby apoyan a joe biden
vamos a matar
ya me que
la verdad es que esta película ya la
hemos visto antes los republicanos en
california e intentaron avivar el miedo
a los inmigrantes ilegales en los años
90 y lo único que les valió fue para
mantener el cargo de gobernador apoyados
en la popularidad de añosos henares pero
desde entonces casi salió nada baby los
hispanos amigos nunca se lo perdonaron y
cada vez los hispanos tienen más que
decir en california y ahora también en
arizona pero llegados a este punto turno
para ti crees que arizona seguirá siendo
un feudo republicano considera es que la
población hispana pasará factura tram
por su discurso ante inmigración déjanos
tu respuesta aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
resultó interesante no olvidéis no
olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
visual político si es que aún no lo
habéis hecho aún no esté suscrito vamos
venga darle rápido en fin una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]
i